こんちわー所社長です皆さんすごくって分かりますまあ名前とで毛振りなんですけども
映像の世界にですね混ざったスモークを焚いて雰囲気を出すようなせいもあるんですよ
例えばよみんな普通に大腰筋李奈琴のパ処理ちょっと切りかかっているのか何か神秘的
な世界買ってませんそれにスモークを焚いて素敵な感じするんですけどもそのスモーク
室内で炊くともう何か
火事が起きたんじゃないかみたいな雰囲気になるんですよ
今日はもういたってシンプルでございます寝てる人がいる部屋に演出用のすごく滝
なくっておきてく火事なーって思った時の反応はどんな感じなのかめていきたいと思い
ます麻婆飯的な意味も込めておりましてねておきましたぼーっとしてるまぁリグ火事だ
あたふたあたふたしたらもう強けれです
寝ておったか乳なと思った瞬間にいかに正しく適切な動きがとれるかどうか
今回見て行きたいと思いますがこれ動画やればに気づいたんですけども家から煙上がっ
てると絶対数だと思うでしょう後の日と呼ばれると思ったんで事前に棄民の準備の皆様
には事前にこういう馬場を取りますよというのを伝えさせていただいております消防の
方にももう届出を出してやって
こういう撮影するというのを言ってるんで alsok の方にも火災保付しっかり
食べていればやっていいよということでオールオッケー各所の日すべての京都をとった
うえで行っておりますちなみに何かドライアイスとかでバーって言うサックス待ったん
ですけどもどうせだからリアルのほうがいい
じゃないですかというわけでわざわざも必要のスモーク準備しました
なので明日の朝五中ターゲットが寝ているときにすごくたく用の特殊部隊の方が来て
くださってエア中をケーブルいただけにして
メーカーされてバーリアで物件ムービー火事が起きると思った瞬間
どう動けるのか見ていきたいと思いますパン alpina と思うよ
俺だったらパニックになるんだけどそこで落ち着くのがすごい大事だと思うんで人間誰
しも生活していると風に縁がないわけじゃないんでしょ
ここで避難訓練できればいいと思っております出会い校
避難訓練する人は顔じゃないんだよなぁ
おやすみ
ん
me
持った
[音楽]
マッハ
さあ
[音楽]
ん
うん
草を私が来たぞありがとうございます汗でドア閉めますねでは私は奥のほうへ室するよ
あそじゃん
こっちでお願いしますこっちであそれはすまんね室でしたねじゃあよろしくお願います
どうぞよろしく
だけで今回スモークを焚いてくださるプロの方ですはい私がスモークのプロです
よろしくねじゃあすごくてどんな感じででべくすごいんですか
やばいぞめなめんなを
前みたいな楽器が使っていい勝負じゃないんだぞ
それすいません失礼しました我が家代々伝わる
スモークキール羨ましいんだこのがそうすれば誰でもイチコロで今からお前を殺す
いやいやその無理ですよもう実践する感じですか
もう手元にある今すぐこの画像編ニジマスのでそうなら大胆に
さん夫婦もかからない10秒もあればこの部屋に毒ガスを充満させることができる
もう香味をこの手元にある頃小さいこれ
ボタン一つだけでボタン1動作外出るからな3だけはあいくぞ
ゆうちぴ
うわぁやばい&クーザあ
ああどうだどうだこれが我が家大鉄あるキラーと僕マシーンだ
っていうことがぶれるこんな小さい欲しいでこれはだにゃー
矢部風でこっち来た今や目晴れやばこれはやだ自分の各社やねこれ俺が橋が
よるとかこれいやもう脚がやられちゃうわこれあじゃない
卒業違いやいで下さい読みくださいそっちかそっち系
おろろーがーやめてくださいやめてください卒中そっち系よろ
2台あるからあなたは他の人猛毒がそしてやるぜ
ええええええ
夜デー
はいというわけで準備完了しましたあの世代のこれ同期ガスじゃないんですただの
スモークのです体に害がないんですと言うところ今から部屋に入れていきたいとおもい
ます
ターゲットでてるんですけどいます
[音楽]
ええん
あ今日はー
スモーク
タクっぽいはぁっはぁっはぁっ
[音楽]
tan tan
すー
を切られたっ
me
チェウ
風おおぉおおっ
うわぁええなぁ bacio ううーー do
[音楽]
ブーブーうーん
はぁっ
ええええパパ思春期
ていた
web 2
和葉だぞ
粋で気に入ってはだぞ8番でやってすごい稼がなければ東京は右手たら突然
といえば煙いただけになる時でしたあーーまず設置したから殺しカーって
ネットがれてるよかはっはー
すぎって生
だ知って趣味
ni
この度は私の軽率な鳥八条
can you tube ええええ
取って仕掛ければ者ビビってられる
81尾シリーズで前でしゃべらんだ